companies in New York City will not be
allowed to ask job applicants about
their salary history under bill the City
Council is expected to pass today it is
part of an effort to reduce the wage gap
for women who often earn less than men
the nation of Iceland is working to
become the first country in the world to
make companies prove they pay equal
wages Michelle Miller is in the capital
city of Reykjavik with a look at the
struggle Michelle good morning good
morning well lawmakers here at Iceland's
Parliament introduced that bill last
week it's still up for debate but
already it's received a groundswell of
support from both women and men and the
nation's prime minister 23 year old milk
orca Maria Goodman's daughter is a
carpenter's apprentice she suspects the
men in her trade are paid more for doing
the same job you don't feel it but when
you see the numbers it's shocking women
in Iceland get paid 14 to 20 percent
less than men but the government here is
trying to close the gender gap with
legislation not just demanding equal pay
but requiring employers to prove it it's
2017 now it's time to mana Iceland's
Prime Minister be Arne benediction leads
the government backing the bill in
Parliament about you know having people
think about it have the human resource
department set up the pay policy
standard and look at the requirements
for each and every job so that gender
does not at the end of the day become
the reason for different pay so you're
making wages more transparent absolutely
absolutely
it's a murky topic worldwide especially
when race is a factor in the US and 2015
white women earned 75 percent of what
their male counterparts took in while
black women earned just 63 percent of
white male earnings and Latina women 54
percent
Iceland is one of the world's most
progressive nations on gender and human
rights issues equal pay laws have been
on the books since 1961 but the country
has been slow to close the wage gap our
goal is to reach this in 2020 to that
soon yeah that's that's our ambition it
takes a long time takes years 70
year-old Guzman Auguste arturis fought
for equal pay most of her life she
helped organize a major strike in 1975
when women in Iceland walked off the job
and out of their homes to show their
worth to the nation people saw that
without women's work the wheel of the
country they they did not turn
everything Stood Still
last October 40 years later
leader Louis Valda mutts daughter joined
thousands to repeat that protest for
equal wages striking a to 38 p.m. the
moment in the day they calculate women
begin working for free you basically did
the math yes and figure it out yeah when
you stopped getting paid yes did people
get it totally women have been fighting
for women's rights for hundreds of years
and this is just a one milestone and
we'd escaped after keep on fighting now
there are just a few voices of
opposition on this bill arguing that the
private sector in particular should be
left alone to police itself the Prime
Minister believes this bill will pass by
the end of the year and he says this
could be the blueprint for a gender pay
equality worldwide really interesting
story really interesting and I hope what
you're saying is true from your lips to
God's ears thank you very much Michelle
Miller and Iceland